[Music]
roseann bears all in a new interview
that was recorded just one day after she
was fired and her show was canceled and
it is clear Roseanne's emotions were raw
I've made myself I hate magnet of course
I am NOT a rapist I'm an idiot the
emotional phone interview between
Roseann and her friend
Rabbi Shmuley lasted nearly 40 minutes
the disgraced comic alternated between
saying a racist tweet is indefensible I
can't defend it I don't want to defend
it to blaming it on her own
ignorant Valerie Jarrett I thought she
was white I did not know she was a black
woman but I'm not stupid for God's sake
and I never would have wedding Lee
called
any black person they say they are a
monkey I definitely did and while the
original Roseanne series often tackled
issues like race with inclusivity and
equality black people are just like us
they're every bit as good as us and any
people who don't think so is just a
bunch of banjo picking cousin datin
barefoot embarrassments to respectable
white trash like us
Roseanne says APC was just not willing
to accept her apology as we know now the
Connors will go on without her this fall
Sara Gilbert briefly acknowledge the
news today on the talk I'm so excited
thank you all so much I really
[Applause]
[Music]